bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques au sommaire de ce
mercredi 6 juillet des concerts des
comédies musicales du théâtre de l'opéra
l'espace coluche de plaisir mise sur
l'éclectisme pour sa prochaine saison
vincent desmo son directeur vient nous
la présenter
du côté du scarabée à la verrière la
programmation rime avec chansons et
concerts l'ex directrice camille abily
by b parlons nous en donne les temps
forts et à maurepas la nouvelle saison
de l'espace albert camus propose des
spectacles pour tous les publics
coup de projecteur avec véronique rocher
adjointe au maire déléguée à l'action
culturelle
on commence ce magazine en musique et
jeudi derniers à la verrière le scarabée
accueillait danakil le groupe il dit
noah se produisait pour les artistes
pour l'eau une association à but
humanitaire regarder ils se sont connus
sur les bancs du lycée 16 ans plus tard
danakil est toujours là le groupe marly
choix c'est dû régler aux inspirations
jamaïcaine et aux textes engagés
on peut dire ce qu'on veut après mois
les mots les étiquettes engagé militants
ont fait la musique qu'on fait il ya des
chansons qui sont plus sérieuses sur
lesquels on essaie de poser des
réflexions carrément employons les gros
mots il y en a d'autres qui sont plus
légères parce que la musique ça sert à
tout ça aussi notre art c'est la musique
donc comme un peintre irait peindre un
petit peu les émotions que lui donne sa
vie va nous ça devient des notes de
musique ça devient des paroles groupe
indépendant danakil était sur la scène
du scarabée le 30 juin dernier pour le
festival les artistes pour l'eau
l'association du même nom vient en aide
aux dogons populations autochtones
armani on était justement sur une
période où on se tournait vers le mali
nous mêmes pour l'enregistrement de
l'album à l'époque le troisième album
qui a été enregistré là-bas les années
qui ont suivi moi j'ai su aller
m'installer au mali j'y ai passé deux
ans donc on était vraiment dans une
dynamique proche tous les uns des autres
et effectivement on sait on sait on
s'est entendu jean eudes et pas nous
notre mission c'est de leur faire des
forages d'essayer de le retrouver l'eau
pure c'est ce qui s'est produit l'année
dernière dans 2013 et 2014
nous avons développé une ferme avicole
et agricoles grâce à l'accès à l'eau on
a commencé par un courage qui a donné
une autre est récurent la rue résonne
leur dernier album sortira le 7 octobre
le premier single 32 mars est inspiré
par le mouvement nuit debout
les rideaux des scènes saint quentinois
se sont fermées pour cette saison
2015-2016 l'occasion maintenant de se
pencher sur la prochaine celle de
2016-2017
et on commence avec la ville de plaisir
et le théâtre espace coluche dans le
sang des animaux soir bonsoir
vous en êtes le directeur et oui je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est avant tout
l'éclectisme qui vous a intéressé cette
année en fait c'est même l'éclectisme et
qui nous intéresse tous les ans c'est
vraiment notre mission d'avoir des
spectacles qui intéresse tous les
publics toutes les tranches d'âge et
toutes les modes artistiques on va dire
il ya des concerts il ya du théâtre de
la comédie musicale et ce à des
spectacles comme un point commun ils
vous ont plu en tant que directeur met
avant tout en tant que spectateur tout à
fait celle que moi je quand je cherche
des spectacles à programmer bien sûr je
pense au public ici en même temps moi le
spectacle ne me plaît pas je peux pas je
dire un gros mot le vendre le proposer
au public avec la passion que j'ai pour
chacun des spectacles que je que je vois
c'est respectable que vous découvrez
comment c'est les artistes c'est les
titres c'est la scène qui vous intéresse
c'est tout tout savoir que je reçois
beaucoup d'invitations j'ai la chance
d'aller travailler avignon pendant deux
semaines voir des spectacles gens voient
ensuite à paris beaucoup en région
parisienne est donc bon après c'est
selon ce que je vois les artistes ça
peut être des artistes connus ça peut
être pris selon le sujet plutôt ça peut
être il faut qu'il y ait une qualité
artistique toujours bien sûr et la
saison reprend les 23 et 24 septembre
c'est un même spectacle ce qui se passe
sur deux jours absolument 23 24
septembre c'est le spectacle que nous
offrons aux spectateurs de plaisir et
les spectateurs du théâtre devrait venir
pas seulement de plaisir c'est le
lancement de saison nous avons une
présentation de saison en juin et la
cellule lancement de saison on offre un
spectacle drôlissime qui s'appelle lady
valhalla des chansons d'amour traficoter
surtout à saisir dans ses spectacles il
ya aussi des têtes d'affiché notamment
le 7 janvier c'est irma la douce avec
lorànt deutsch et nicole croisille qu'on
ne présente le avant d'en parler je vous
propose de regarder un extrait là c'est
de la comédie musicale de l'humour de la
légèreté est aussi la volonté du théâtre
oui c'est de l'humour de la légèreté
c'est surtout à la fois apporter un
sujet le spectacle est un divertissement
de toute façon ça doit on doit venir se
changer les idées se divertir ça
n'empêche pas d'apporter des sujets à
mon sens des sujets parfois plus
difficiles ou d'apporter une réflexion
là la comédie musicale ça pour être un
style un peu désuet et non finalement
c'est toujours d'actualité
abbas et surtout monté par nicolas
briançon donc là on est vraiment dans
l'actualité parce que c'est pas une
comédie musicale jeunes les airs sont
connus on les reconnaît tous il ya quand
même
marie julie baup sic et donc qui chante
merveilleusement bien et et puis à
nicole croisille qui m'a complètement
bluffé beaucoup de cas encore plus que
toute la sélection que vous avez fait
c'est un des coups de coeur parmi tous
les autres
effectivement et justement parmi tous
les autres parmi ces spectacles ont dû
plein d'humour il ya pianiste au logis
symphonique de 6000 fâchent là aussi je
pose regardez un extrait et c'est assez
rigolo
et
à
non
qu'est ce qui vous a plu chez simon
fâche son talent déjà quand je les ai
vus avignon il était tout seul dans une
toute petite salle de la rue des
teinturiers
effectivement c'est cet humour musical
il a il nous apporte
comment dirais-je le classique et en le
rapprochant des pme regarder la télé ou
au piano avec tous derrière un thème
classique est en fait en plus quand il
vient au théâtre espace coluche il va
venir avec 60 musiciens
donc c'est de l'humour musical mais avec
un tel talent pour ça pour information
il fait quand même l'ouverture du jazz
du festival de jazz de montreux tous les
ans j'ai vraiment aimé il est adorable
en plus donc c'est vraiment un excellent
spectacle et vous disiez tout à l'heure
il ya des sujets
moins drôle on va dire plus grave les
chatouilles vous pouvez m'en parler en
quelques mots très rapidement les
chatouilles c'est un spectacle sur
l'inceste donc lui bon c'est pas facile
ce qui est génial dans la mise en scène
de métayer et avec cette comédienne
séquence eric métayer pardon c'est qu'en
fait toutes les parties quotidiennes du
quotidien qui ne sont pas difficiles
sans parler c'est plutôt assez drôle un
moment parce que elle imite la prof de
danse du cours de danse d'un petit
village du sud enfin c'est drôlissime
tout ce qui est indicible l'inceste et
danser c'est la danse contemporaine qui
d'une violence mais d'une beauté
incroyable
chaque fois que j'en parle j'ai des
frissons et c'est cette façon d'apporter
ce sujet difficile sans le sens les mots
qui sont parfois trop difficile à
entendre avec la danse c'est superbe
et là aussi justement pour apporter une
illustration votre propos un court
extrait le modèle moi j'ai pas comme toi
c'est pourquoi il a fallu qu'il danse
alors comprends madame on comprend
maintenant je comprends rien alors là
parler de spectacle un peu plus adaptée
aux adultes mais les plus jeunes ne sont
pas oubliés
absolument pas lily à une programmation
jeune public de six à huit spectacles
selon les saisons
toutes les saisons et ce sont aussi des
spectacles dans la peau vraiment les
divertir les amuser les détendre il ya
notamment un spectacle sur la magie
l'école des magiciens qui est très drôle
etc
et puis nous fêtons réussir à vous le
dire nous fêtons nos dix ans la saison
prochaine
voilà donc toujours autant de spectacles
toujours autant de volonté de la part de
la ville de culture de l'ouvrir à tous
et d'abord de la culture et du spectacle
vivant surtout du spectacle vivant
merci à denis en plateau il ya beaucoup
de choses à dire une saison c'est
complet alors pour la découvrir
direction le site internet de l'espl
théâtre espace coluche la billetterie la
billetterie est déjà ouverte tout autre
sujet elle a peut-être verser
l'adolescence de plusieurs d'entre vous
hélène rollès plus connu sous le nom
hélène actrice et chanteuse devenue
célèbre dans les années 1990 grâce aux
séries premier baiser ou hélène et les
garçons elle était en dédicace cet après
midi au magasin carrefour de saint
quentin en yvelines pour son dernier
album on les écoute
elle était au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
c'est un juste retour des choses je
trouve voilà on n'existe pas ce qui nous
regarde et donc enfin la série existe un
par le voilà et parce que parce que les
gens regardent donc c'est un échange et
ça me fait plaisir de pouvoir les
rencontrer et de leur faire plaisir
surtout le retour c'est leur amour
voilà leur fidélité et les gentils tout
et gentillesse qui me disent les cadeaux
les et puis puis les rendez-vous à
l'olympia voilà on a rendez-vous il a
beaucoup qui font signer les places déjà
on reparle programmation de la prochaine
saison et le scarabée mise elle sur la
musique et la chanson camilla belle baie
bonsoir bon ça y est la directrice du
scarabée
ça débute le 14 octobre avec un concert
de thomas fersen une présentation rapide
de l'artiste alors thomas fersen c'est
un grand déjà de la chanson française
c'est quelqu'un qui nous a séduit par
son écriture très particulière précise
les très poétique et c'est en même temps
un vrai raconteur d'histoires donc c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qu'on avait envie de
faire depuis longtemps et voilà
l'occasion se présente on est très
heureux de l'accueillir
vous l'avez découvert à quelques mots je
vous propose de le découvrir cette fois
en images
et là prennent le fun les cheveux qu'ils
en aient ses grosses mains d'être en
bonne santé ça y est cette bonne artiste
pour que débuter une saison oscars avait
oui parce que le scarabée depuis
longtemps à privilégie la chanson dans
sa programmation artistique
donc voila c'était un choix quasi
naturelle comment vous les découvrez ces
artistes comme ça on les découvre un peu
partout on va vous voir beaucoup de
spectacle on a la chance d'être dans une
région où l'offre est très importante et
puis on se déplace aussi sur de
différents festivals pour aller écouter
artistes plus ou moins connus pour faire
des petits coups de coeur et après le
choix est parfois difficile pour la
saison et dans vos coups de coeur
justement il y en a qui seront en
résidence au mois d'octobre les petites
bourrettes ils présentent leur dernier
album avant d'en parler on regarde un
extrait on se demande toujours à quoi
pensent et pourquoi elle est plus elle
regarde les autres qui dansent drake a
l'air un peu perdu
y a pas grand-chose qui l'impressionnent
n'y a pas grand monde qui la questionne
pourquoi alors avoir proposé une
résidence alors c'est des artistes de la
région
donc on est toujours ravi quand on peut
donner aussi un petit coup de pouce aux
artistes du coin
c'est un groupe qui tourne depuis
longtemps qu on avait déjà entendu vu à
droite à gauche jamais eu l'occasion de
faire et là ils étaient à la recherche
d'un lieu pour travailler sur leur
nouveau spectacle puis sortent un album
cet été le 26 août et du coup il va y
travaille la scène avec les nouvelles
chansons donc ce sera au scarabée avec
un concert le 4 novembre juste après la
résidence vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est des artistes un peu moins connu du
grand public ont précisé qu'ils ont
quand même leur leur entourage qui les
suivent mais c'est une mission du
scarabée aussi de faire découvrir au
grand public justement masse est
essentiel parce que si on proposait pas
de nouvelles choses aux spectateurs on
n'aurait plus jamais de tête d'affiche
non plus ça se construit un artiste
petit à petit
de scène en scène de concert en concert
et donc notre rôle c'est aussi ça de
proposer des choses un peu différentes
de ce qu'on voit à la télévision dans
des grandes salles là c'est une demi
saison au scarabée ça fonctionne en
données saison et on a parlé de deux
enfants il y en a un troisième
là c'est extrêmement drôle ce sont les
banquettes arrière
regardez un extrait on en parle juste
après les parties les plus intimes comme
aja cette anatomie mais je remarque avec
émoi que met en rouge et plein d'humour
oui beaucoup d'humour sur cette soirée
là c'est une soirée récurrente au
scarabée tous les ans on fait à
l'occasion du beaujolais nouveau
une soirée avec un petit repas et puis
une association qui tient une buvette
sous le thème soudain sur un thème
humoristique avec de l'humour musical et
la tombée sur ces trois comédiennes qui
viennent de la rue du tas de rue qui
chante a cappella et qui sont des
petites bombes d'énergie et avec leurs
propres créations c'est pas un trio
agricole beaucoup mais c'est de la
création pure là et celles qui écrivent
oui toulouse qui ont écrit tout le
spectacle
donc on a ces trois temps forts d'un
point de vue pratique si les gens sont
intéressés ne serait ce que par ses
trois concerts comment ça se passe alors
la billetterie sera ouverte à partir de
la semaine prochaine
donc à partir du 11 juillet on peut
acheter des places en ligne sur la
luciole s'affichant en bas de l'écran
merci en plateau pour nous présenter
cette saison donc pour découvrir les
artistes les dates et les horaires
on a dit l'adresse est tout de suite en
bas de l'écran on parlait des talents de
ce qui fonde la scène
professionnellement il ya aussi les
jeunes les jeunes saint quentinois ont
du talent c'est en tout cas ce que pour
cela commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
samedi dernier elle organisait
concours de jeunes talents en
partenariat notamment avec le centre
alfred de vigny retour sur cette soirée
elle est douce et timide elle va nous
avons nous interpréter maman de la
chanteuse one donc à tonnerre
d'applaudissements mais derrière comme
marianne ils sont plus d'une trentaine à
avoir tenté leur chance
ils ont entre 11 et 25 ans et participe
au concours des jeunes talents de
voisins-le-bretonneux je fais de la
musique depuis longtemps depuis toujours
même et j'avais envie de faire un petit
concert comme ça profitant de l'été et
puis en plus il y avait un concours de
talent donc si je veux partir de me
faire un peu connaître pourquoi pas
sinon à s'amuser tout en étant un départ
timide et donc
c'est une expérience aussi ça nous
permet de faire les séances de l'année
voir comment ça se déroule à dieu
surtout après six mois de répétitions
ces candidats sont évalués par un jury
d'experts
jules de radio sensations andy de déclic
théâtre ou encore un membre du conseil
municipal des jeunes suivent une grille
d'évaluation
la grande partie techniques artistiques
et après il ya le volet ceiling le bonus
inning le bonus l'insee si on a bien
ressenti ou pas si on a aimé c'est le
petit plus c'est nous et fait chaud au
coeur ou si nous importe radi après il y
aura technique et artistique
voilà c'est l'emplacement de la scène
comment la personne arrive à s'en sortir
le concours est né de la collaboration
de plusieurs partenaires notamment le
service jeunesse de la commune et le
centre alfred de vigny c'est de mettre
en avant les jeunes donc de 11 à 25 ans
de les mettre dehors un espace scénique
de les faire monter sur scène avec des
talents que ce soit dans le domaine du
chant dans domaine musical
il ya aussi de la magie
y'avait aussi éventuellement des arts du
cirque pour cette première édition c'est
aymeric 12 ans imitateur de michael
jackson qui l'emportent pas de palme
pour les autres mais ils ont déjà
conquis le public et on continue le
kiosque avec notre troisième invité et
une troisième salle de spectacle on part
à maurepas et à l'espace albert camus et
pour parler de cette programmation
véronique rocher bon ça bonsoir je vous
êtes adjointe au maire déléguée à
l'action culturelle alors l'espace
albert camus c'est avant tout des
spectacles tout public
oui effectivement on s'adresse aux
familles aux enfants mais on n'oublie
pas les seniors est effectivement notre
programmation s'adresse aux scolaires
qui nous amène aux familles les
scolaires c'est à dire qu'il ya des
spectacles plus adapté pour eux qu'ils
pourraient faire découvrir aux parents
comment ça se passe oui c'est ça alors
en fait on propose aux écoles des
spectacles et puis ils peuvent les
parents peuvent découvrir par la suite
ses spectacles effectivement et dans
cette programmation il y a deux temps
forts le premier est en mars
c'est un pianiste farfelu s'appelle
gilles ramade une présente piano furious
oh oui qu'est-ce qu'il a plus que c'est
pourquoi cet artiste là c'est un artiste
qui allie la chanson le cirque la
comédie la danse
il est très joyeux pétillant et on s'est
dit que voilà il improvise et ces voix
là c'est la c1 dans les tacles salle
arts de la scène ouvert à tous c'est
justement là aussi regarder un extrait
cette année
c'est de la chanson française entendu
michel sardou ça s'adresse à tout le
monde
exactement à tous et puis et puis il
faut pas oublier que camus et coller à
notre conservatoire et que c'est vrai
qu'on avait quand même on souhaite
mettre en valeur la musique toute
musique dont celle là bien évidemment
mais aussi la musique classique
et puis grâce au café de la plage on à
la musique actuelle donc vraiment on a
un espace musical assez vaste et l'aja
maurepas et justement musique s'il a une
tête d'affiché dans votre programmation
cette année c'est emmanuel rossfelder à
ce que vous pouvez me le présente alors
emmanuel rossfelder s'est éteint c'est
un concertiste de renommée mondiale ont
ils se privent s'est présenté sur des
grandes scènes nationales et
internationales donc un guitariste ben
oui il a été élève de la goya donc
classique effectivement et en même temps
accessible à la hausse car ça permet
aussi peut-être les classiques ça ne
m'atteint peu désuète des fois il est
quand même victoires de la musique
classique en demi finale s'il a eu des
premiers prix en battant national de
paris il vient du conservatoire du
conservatoire d'aix en provence
donc c'est mais beaucoup de chance
valeur la culture française exactions en
exactement
voilà on a cette chance à maurepas de
pouvoir les cueillir on a parlé de ses
deux enfants y en a un qui commence un
peu plus tôt qui commence en septembre
et c'est un premier spectacle à l'issue
de la présentation générale de la
programmation république va s'y passer
quoi ce jour là donc c'est un spectacle
plutôt rigolo on va dire avec de deux
acteurs qui allie toutes sortes de deux
mètres mille façons de se présenter sur
scène le chant la comédie le cirque
voilà et on s'est dit qu'on avait envie
d'offrir aux mort passe bien cette
journée leur donner envie de revenir à
camus bien sûr donc à cette occasion là
on leur présentera la saison culturelle
il en a parlé de professionnels maurepas
l'espace albert camus aussi propose la
scène aux amateurs absolument ya chaque
année
pleins feux sur les plans jouer un mois
un mois en résidence on perd mais on
permet à des associations de théâtre
amateur d'être une semaine en résidence
et de présenter voilà leur leurs scènes
de théâtre alors leur pièce de théâtre
pardon et et voilà c'est la troisième
année consécutive c'est très demandé ça
marche très très bien et je crois que
c'est une bonne chose aussi de pour ces
amateurs de pouvoir se présenter d'avoir
un public c'est important compagnie
amateur en résidence ils sont
sélectionnés d'abord non on donne aux
sondés y sont au sud du territoire
voilà il y en a certains dont certaines
ne mord pas ou de coignières elles sont
là elles se présentent à nous et on les
prend en résidence le monde et ça se
renouvelle chaque année c'est le succès
c'est la troisième année
effectivement et gl redemande bien sûr
merci vers les crochets d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation donc la saison 2016
2017 de l'espace albert camus de nos
repas sera lancé le 24 septembre
on n'a pas donné la date tout à l'heure
c'est en après midi la billetterie
ouvrira ses portes elle lors du forum
des associations au début du mois de
septembre et on passe maintenant à une
page cinéma avec les nouveautés à la
fiche on écoute les réactions des
amateurs de 7e à elles ont été
recueillies par maintenant labat il
c'était un beau film sur la nature les
paysages
les animaux vos rapports des animaux
avec l'homme surtout d'aller le voir au
cinéma ça savons bien sur grand écran
franchement j'ai pas du tout aimé le
film ben le premier je les trouvais
beaucoup plus marrant je suis là j'ai
trouvé un peu grossier les sketchs il
n'était pas
oui c'était un peu grossier et papa de
ne pas originaux en fait j'ai bien aimé
enfin c'était marrant et on s'est bien
amusé
j'étais un peu sceptique j'ai suivi
monsieur et au final beaucoup de cartes
donc aucun j'ai pas vu le temps passer
rejet des acteurs est très bien et puis
tarzan et agréable à voir on se rende
maintenant que les sous bois pour le
coup de coeur du professionnel cette
semaine ses scieries la date du cinéma
philippe noiret qui nous le donne
regardez cette semaine notre coup de
coeur est tout de suite maintenant de
pascal bonitzer avec agathe bonitzer
lambert wilson et vincent lacoste n'aura
sator jeune trentenaire dynamique
commença sa carrière dans la haute
finance et quand elle apprend que son
patron et sa femme ont fréquenté son
père dans leur jeunesse
elle découvre qu'une mystérieuse
rivalité les opposent encore sur un
scénario très élaborés et totalement
maîtrisé pascal bonitzer réunit une
formidable bande d'acteurs juste dans ce
qui ressemble à son meilleur long
métrage
en effet le film permet à agathe
bonitzer et vincent lacoste de révéler
avec virtuosité les rôles qui leur ont
été confiées
lambert wilson manipulateurs comme jean
pierre bacri bourgon rejoue une
partition qu'ils ont interprété à
maintes reprise et le font toujours
aussi bien c'est un des charmes du film
le réalisateur parvient à ficeler une
intrigue solide autour de la notion de
faux semblants le film superbement écrit
et interprété il réduira à n'en pas
douter le spectateur tout de suite et
maintenant est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe le ray
j'espérais tueur est votre ambition dans
la vie que faire du fric dans une botte
de finances que mater sur ce point comme
sur tous les autres font 50 perd c'est
un mec intelligent 5
en fait j'ai une super carte forte chose
qui est maintenant terminée vous pourrez
retrouver l'émission en replay sur notre
site internet je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine